Right?
Well,
the,
the glorious revolution of 60,
98 so-called,
um,
which I described last time began as a relatively bloodless coup,
but it did go on to usher in some pretty massive changes in the structure of
government and also in Britain standing in the world.
Um,
in the 20 years after the revolution,
Britain began to emerge as one of Europe's great powers.
And we look at that in the final full lecture,
uh,
after the break.
But part of understanding that change requires us to understand how Britain was
able to sustain that kind of role after 60 and 88.
And that brings us back to the economy,
especially in the late 17th and dirty 18th centuries.
So you have your lovingly handcrafted handout,
he sort of artists and hand out,
uh,
and,
that contains the basic facts and they'll take you through it.
Um,
I wasn't noticed whenever I announced there's going to be electron economic
history that seems to have the same effect as the great plague of 1666 on our
numbers,
but,
uh,
it,
it matters.
Okay.
Right.
Well,
a few weeks ago,
um,
I left the narrative of economic and social change at the point in the mid 17th
century when population and prices began to stabilize after over a century of
growth.
Um,
but as I said,
then the dynamic of change that had been unleashed in the latest 16th and dirty
17th centuries didn't stop.
Rather,
it continued in a changing and increasingly favorable climate.
And central to that new context was the relative stability of population and
prices in 1641,
as you'll see on table one of your handout,
the population was just over 5 million and it remained at approximately that
level for many decades to come.
In fact,
in some parts of the late 17th century population growth rates for particular
decades where in fact negative in 1,701 and the population was still just over 5
million and it was only about five and a half million by the mid 18th century.
Renewed growth didn't start until the late 18th century.
Well,
the reasons for this relative stability,
um,
seem fairly clear in the light of research by demographic historians.
Um,
as table two indicates fertility as measured by the gross rate of reproduction
reached it's Nadiia in the third quarter of the 17th century.
And thereafter from about the sixties and seventies,
it began to recover a little but very,
very slowly.
And it didn't reach it 16th century levels again until after 1760.
Any potential that there might have been for renewed growth was choked off by
two further factors.
First of all,
the late 17th century saw a decline in life expectation at birth.
It was as low as 33 on average by the end of the 17th century.
It's a paradox that mortality was so bad in a period which actually saw the
final disappearance of plague from Britain.
The outbreak in London in 1665 to six was the last great outbreak,
but the absence of that kind of crisis mortality didn't prevent generally high
levels of what the demographers referred to as background mortality from
infectious diseases.
One of the Mary Dobson has shown that high levels of mortality were particularly
associated with urban centers with low lying areas,
with poor water supplies,
with the growing industrial areas of the kingdom and with the areas along
significant trade routes.
And her suggestion is that these facts are the outcome of in the first place,
dense concentrations of population in the cities and also those areas which shed
that density in the countryside and which were linked by communications,
which made the transmission of infectious diseases that much easier and more
closely interconnected society was one in which disease transmission could take
place more effectively.
So mortality was pretty bad in the late 17th century.
And secondly,
a further factor was migration.
That was partly overseas migration.
Uh,
between 1650 and 60,
99,
almost a quarter of a million migrants left England for overseas destinations,
mostly to the Americas,
mostly going either to the West indies or to the southern colonies of mainland
America as indentured servants.
And the second part of the migration factor was internal migration,
internal movement of people to the rather unhealthy urban centers and industrial
centers.
The high death rates in those places did much to wipe out the surplus births of
healthier areas as people moved into less healthy urban or industrial centers.
So population stability for almost a century.
The Century after 1650 also saw a new era in price trends and they're
represented on section three of your handout.
As you'll see from that,
the index shows that the prices of wheat and barley,
the principal bread corns,
we're actually falling from the 1650s through to about the 16th eighties and
then after a few bad harvests in the 60 nineties they fluctuated at about 20%
below the level they had been in the mid 17th century.
In contrast,
the prices of meats remained fairly stable,
even rose modestly.
The impact of this falling prices for bread,
corn,
stable prices for meat on the standards of the common people was quite
considerable.
The actual wage rates that people were being paid didn't change a great deal in
the late 17th century,
but people,
real wages,
the purchasing power of their wages increased quite substantially for the first
time in over a century.
So the evidence suggested by the 1680s real wages,
the purchasing power of wages were up by about 50% over the levels of the 16th
thirties
for people who could find regular work,
the costs of feeding their families were falling and that released some
purchasing power for goods over and above those that they needed for basic
subsistence.
So then population stabilization,
declining prices of basic agricultural products,
growing real wages for craftsman and wage laborers.
And to understand the outcome of these trends,
we have to remember that all of this has happening in what was already a more
commercialized economy in which the livelihoods of most people were increasingly
dependent on the markets for their products and their labor in a more integrated
economy.
And the outcome of all of this was a further development in the processes of
economic growth,
which had been set in motion earlier.
One can sum it all up as being a process of increased regional economic
specialization,
intensified national economic integration,
and also increasing participation in a nascent world economy.
That sounds very grand,
but we can follow through with the processes step by step as to how all of this
fit together
in agriculture.
The key to change was basically the fact that although markets for different
products had stabilized somewhat and reoriented,
they didn't actually decline the population stabilized,
but it didn't decline.
There was still a large market for agricultural produce and that placed general
pressure on commercial farmers to try to keep up their market share by reducing
their unit costs and competing with other farmers to produce more and more
effectively at prices,
which would enable their profit margins to remain reasonable.
And that meant a renewed emphasis on agricultural improvement.
Basically,
one can say that the late 17th century saw a more general spread of many of the
innovations in agricultural techniques,
which I described coming in in the late 16th and early 17th centuries.
It's been said by one agricultural historian that many of the novel techniques
of a century earlier had become general practice,
general best practice by the early 18th century.
All of that involved and was part in parcel of a general regional reorientation
in land use.
Uh,
increasingly the east and the southeast of the country,
we're predominantly Arabelle that was the best price area for cereals.
Um,
it had major markets in London and the towns of the southeast and also markets
in nearby continental Europe.
But elsewhere in the kingdom,
livestock husbandry became more prevalent in the north and in the west.
They'd always had a bias towards livestock.
It became more marked.
Um,
one mustn't exaggerate all this into complete regional homogeneity,
but there's a definite trend towards specialization of that kind within
particular agricultural countries.
And that made easier the diffusion and adoption of innovations by example.
People saw what their neighbors were doing.
There's an excellent accountable of this by,
uh,
one of the writers of the late 17th century,
John Aubrey,
who describes what was happening in his home,
county of wheelchair down in the southwest to the southwest of Oxford and in
wheelchair or be describes how various innovations were brought in.
He names names,
who was the first to do this or to do that.
And he describes how their neighbors copied them when they saw the particular
innovations were successful and profitable.
Overall,
the whole process greatly raised agricultural output.
It's been estimated that the cereal's yield in eastern and southeastern England
was up by about 40% between 1650 and 1750 and in dry environment.
Then of rising agricultural productivity induced by a more competitive
commercial climate.
Well,
that agricultural specialization facilitated and wasn't in turn encouraged by
the continued growth of the urban population and the continued growth of the
population in the non agricultural rural areas,
the rural areas where many people were employed in various kinds of industry
and in turn growing agricultural productivity released labor for nonagricultural
occupations and enhanced the purchasing power of those who live by wages in such
occupations.
One of the most striking features of the late 17th and 18th centuries is that
although population as a whole stabilized the population of the towns and the
population of the rural industrial areas continued to grow.
Both absolutely and relatively.
There was a regional redistribution of population table for a shows,
the figures which have been calculated for this by EA Wrigley.
As you'll see if you look at for a rural agricultural population declined from
just over 60% in the sixties and seventies to about 46% by the 1750s those
living in towns of more than 5,000 rows from just over 13% to about 21% of the
national population and those living in rural ag non agricultural areas rose for
about 26 to about 33% over the same period.
Now a good deal of that urban growth was of course as you would expect
occasioned by London as usual.
By 1700 London had a population of 575,000 and was the biggest city in Europe.
By 1750 its population had reached 675,000 so London continued to grow in
absolute terms,
but in fact its share of the national population had somewhat stabilized at
about 11%
what seems to have been happening that was that a great deal of the urban growth
of this period was going on in other towns as well.
So for example,
in 1600 England had had 20 towns with a population of more than 5,000
by 1670 it had 26 by 1700 it had 32
provincial cities have more than 5,000 inhabitants were making up an increasing
proportion of the national population by 1700 probably something like five and a
half percent.
By 1750 it was closer to 10%
all of this amounted to a kind of re articulation going on within the hierarchy
of towns and cities.
Obviously London remained at the top on challengingly,
but some historic regional centers was stabilizing or growing only very slowly.
The Old City of York,
for example with remained stable at about 12,000 population through most of this
period.
The real growth was going on in different kinds of towns.
It was going on above all imports,
especially the port of the West.
If you look at table four B Bristol,
the principal port of the west of England grows from about 20,000 population in
1670 to 50,000 by 1750 Liverpool which was emerging from having been a small
market town in the early 17th century,
grew from about 5,000 people in 1672 about 22,000 in 1750
the other kinds of towns which were growing disproportionately seemed to have
been industrial centers.
Newcastle in the northeast based on the coal trade,
grew from 12,000 to 29,000 in the period covered by our table.
Leeds center of the woods did manufacturers in the cloth industry from 6,000 to
16,000 Birmingham Center of metalworking from 6,000 to 24,000
yeah.
This shift was especially pronounced at the turn of the 18th century.
It's been shown that in the early decades of the 18th century,
whereas his what had been described as 10 historic centers,
old cathedral cities and so forth,
grew in population by only 18% a sample of eight ports shows 58% growth and a
sample of new manufacturing towns.
159% growth.
So the urban system was becoming more polycentric.
It had more major centers than it had done.
And as would be apparent from what I've already said,
the dynamic of growth was in commerce,
in trade and in industry taking off in the late 17th century and accelerating in
the early 18th century.
Yeah.
So let's turn to what was going on there to commerce about what you've already
read.
The little,
okay.
In the 1960s as a result of the work of Ralph Davis,
who was the first economic historian to really map the trends in trade in this
period,
people began to talk of the late 17th century as a period of commercial
revolution,
which is a description which,
which has some,
uh,
justice to it.
The focus in Davis's work was on the major growth of extra European trade,
especially with the Americas and with the east.
Yeah.
Now,
in considering this,
it's important always to remember that the well established trades with European
countries continued and indeed in many ways they grew.
But the overall pattern of overseas trade was undoubtedly shifting as
initiatives which had been pioneered by enterprising people in the early 17th
century began to pay off,
became consolidated and extended,
and there are four major aspects of this change which are illustrated in
different ways.
On the second side of your handout and these fingers dealing with overseas
trade,
the first can be illustrated if we look at London's domestic exports in section
a of that table.
As it shows in 1640 on the eve of the civil war,
London's exports were still dominated by woolen cloth.
Some 92% of exports were woolen cloth.
By the latest 1660s though that was down to 74% and by 1700 it was down to 72%
now that change took place not because woolen exports were actually declining,
but because of the rise of other kinds of domestic exports,
greater exports of food stuffs and of raw materials,
agricultural products,
fish lead tin,
Cole animal hides that had together all of that together.
It made up only 5% of London's exports.
In 1640 it was over 12% by 1700 and then the export from London of other
domestic manufacturers,
2.6% of London's exports in 1640 just over 15% by 1700 so the reorientation in
the export trade in domestic products.
Secondly,
if we look at London's imports,
which is section B of the table,
that brings out the continued growth in the value of imports from established
European trading partners,
wines from southern Europe as you'll see growing dramatically in the value of
these imports between the 1630s and the 60 nineties silks,
again,
often from France or southern Europe rising quite significantly.
Iron and steel imports mostly from Scandinavia,
from Sweden in particular,
rising dramatically from 16,000 to 118,000 pounds value.
So considerable growth in the imports from these European trading partners,
but that was dwarfed by the importer to are coming in from the East and the
Americas.
Those imports,
we're increasingly becoming predominant in London's import trade,
so we have continued growth in such commodities as pepper and tobacco,
but massive growth in the import of Calico's.
That's cheap cotton cloth from India and sugar from the West indies almost.
Well,
a five fold increase in the value of the sugar imported from the West indies in
the later 17th century.
Thirdly,
a great deal of these new imported goods.
We're not commute,
we're not consumed domestically,
but we're re export it to European markets.
So for example,
two thirds of the tobacco that was landed in England was reexported to European
markets,
mostly in northern Europe.
A third of the sugar that was landed was re-exported to Europe.
Nine tenths of the pepper that came in from the east was reexported.
You can look at the rising value of those re-exports in table five c we have the
value of domestic exports,
the value of imports and the value of re-exports and look how it grows.
In the course of the late 17th and early 18th centuries,
what was happening then was a flood of tobacco sugar Calico.
Other products coming in from distant overseas origins,
which was then reexported bringing income to the English merchants who
reexported it to Europe.
One of the interesting things about all of these products is that they would,
cheap hogs,
head of tobacco might be expensive in itself,
and by the time it was broken down into small parcels or sold by the pipe,
it had a mass market.
It was cheap.
Similarly,
sugar sugar might be in the form of a great Sugarloaf,
but by the time something had been chipped off,
it wrapped up and sold in small quantities.
It had a mass market.
Calico cloth was very cheap,
the kind of tip and colorful Indian cotton cloth,
which was still familiar with,
which could be bought by servants,
a mass market for these goods.
And in fact,
the figures that we have here don't tell us the whole story.
It's well known that there was a great deal of smuggling and evading the
customs.
The fingers are based on the customer's records.
The reality may have been even greater change than the figures actually
represent,
right?
Well,
these new trades were based upon and involved elaborating more complex and
multilateral trading patterns.
The fourth feature of the change in trade,
these are often described as the triangular trades.
So for example,
you would get vessels leaving the western ports of Britain for the fisheries and
the North Atlantic around Newfoundland,
from which they would bring the dried card to southern Europe where it was in
great demand,
and then they would bring southern European products back to Britain.
A triangle or ships would leave London usually heading for the east indies.
They would trade around east indies between the Indian mainland and what's now
Indonesia and then bring products back to Britain.
The most famous of these triangles,
of course,
there's the so called Atlantic triangle,
the export of manufactured products,
weaponry and liquor to west Africa,
the buying there of slaves to be taken across to the Caribbean and the southern
mainland colonies,
the notorious Atlantic triangle
that was of course a ghastly trade with terrible mortality of both the slaves
and indeed the English crews on the middle passage.
But it was vital to the development of the Atlantic economy and contemporary
simply seem to have accepted it as such.
Little comment initially on what it involved.
A few voices raised in protest,
so are in itself of course,
was nothing new.
What was new was the scale and system systemize systematization of the trade as
it developed in the late 17th and early 18th centuries,
and if it offered any ray of hope in all of this,
it was simply that as people became more familiar with its realities,
voices began to be raised against it,
but not yet.
This transformation of trade was well established by the 16th eighties and then
it stabilized and continued to grow steadily right through to the mid 18th
century and indeed beyond and all of it was vigorously defended by legislation.
The navigation acts,
which made every effort to keep these trades in English hands.
Certain goods could only be exported to the colonies in English ships.
Certain goods could only be landed in England before being reexported to other
destinations.
An effort to keep this new burgeoning trade in the hands of English merchants
and in particular to squeeze out the greatest competitors,
the Dutch.
Okay,
well this expansion of overseas trade created income,
obviously it created employment in shipping in the commercial infrastructure of
the growing port cities.
It was directly linked in that way to urban growth
at above all of London.
Of course,
three quarters of English overseas trade still went through half the merchant
fleet was based in London.
London was a dominant center for shipbuilding and repairing all the ancillary
crafts of the shipping industry.
It was a center for sugar refining and tobacco processing and many other
manufacturers linked to trade silk for example,
but increasingly the so called outputs the other ports,
we're getting a bigger share.
London's relative dominance especially in the Atlantic and re-export trades was
being whittled down somewhat by 1700 about a third of tobacco imports by value
and about a fifth of sugar imports by value came in not through London but
through out ports like Bristol and Liverpool and after the union between England
and Scotland,
the city of Glasgow,
which became the major British center of the tobacco trade as the 18th century
advanced.
Yeah.
The health of trade was also of immense significance to the development of other
industries,
both directly and indirectly.
Of course the trade in woolen textiles which remains so important had always
been heavily influenced by overseas markets.
For high quality wool and cloth.
That continued to be the case,
but the new trades also established new markets for both traditional and new
goods.
Prominent amongst these markets sort of course the Americas and the growing
colonies there.
In 1686 a survey of London's exports that year shows that London was already
exporting 598 different commodities to North America in 329 ships.
If you want to know they were going to Barbados,
to Jamaica,
to the Chesapeake colonies,
to New England.
The total value was prodigious and it involved trade in textiles,
in clothing,
in metal wares,
in miscellaneous manufacturers which were not produced in the colonies
themselves.
For example,
in 1686 they export it to the colonies.
3000 wine glasses.
They exported 6,000 saddles.
These new markets encouraged bulk manufacturer.
They encourage the production of standardized goods,
which could be audit and could be produced by workers who were required to
produce a certain standardized article in the putting out industries.
So bulk manufacturer of standardized goods was steadily growing.
Another feature of industrial change,
so developing markets for English products where of powerful significance,
but much of the output of manufacturing industries were still consumed at home.
As I've already indicated.
Cheaper food raised real incomes for ordinary people,
gave them a margin above their basic subsistence needs.
At least at some point in their life cycle.
They had more spending power and that money was often spent on simple,
cheap manufactured goods,
Calico,
cloth linen,
domestic utensils and so forth.
Moreover,
a lot of the additional income which was being generated in trade and
manufacturers themselves income which went to the mercantile and commercial
classes,
the middle sort of people enable those people to afford a greater variety of
goods which are often described as the decencies of life,
not luxuries,
not necessities,
but the decencies of life.
Often domestic goods of one kind or another or better clothing
taken together.
The new overseas markets and the growing domestic markets encouraged the
development of a larger,
a stronger and a more flexible industrial base.
Tech textiles,
for example,
woolen cloth manufacturer continued as a major industry.
There was a continued diversification of its products,
partly for particular overseas markets.
The cloth weaving villages of the West country,
for example,
produced most of the trade blankets which went to supply the fur traders in
North America.
The wonderful Hudson Bay blankets,
which you can still buy in Canada.
Uh,
they're still made in the west of England.
These colorful trade blankets,
which you see in portraits of native Americans in the late 18th and early 19th
centuries were already been produced specifically for that market in West
Yorkshire,
in the area around Leeds and Bradford.
There was a great growth in another dimension of the woolen cloth industry,
the production of Worcester cloth.
It was aimed at the cheaper end of the market,
mostly domestic in Lancashire around Manchester.
They were further significant new developments.
Manchester lying just to the east of Liverpool in that area.
The linen manufacturing industry became concentrated in the late 17th century,
producing not only linen for domestic needs,
but also producing sail cloth for the growing merchant fleet and canvas.
The Manchester area gradually shifted over from linen to the development of
cotton manufacturing.
They were imitating the imported cotton cloth from India trying to produce it at
home by 1700 a million pounds,
a year's worth of raw cotton was being important.
Much of advice Liverpool to supply that growing industry.
The cotton at this stage tended to come from the Mediterranean rather than North
America by the 1740 2 million pounds a year worth of raw cotton for Manchester's
looms.
The finished cotton cloth had a big market at home and it was also exported to
West Africa and to the Americas,
so by 1750 the Manchester area when a survey was done had almost 5,000 looms
working,
producing cotton.
That was an important precursor of things that were to come in the cotton
industry of Lancashire,
but as yet many of the really significant developments were outside tech styles.
The pottery industry was taking off in the West Midlands in Staffordshire to the
north of Birmingham.
First of all,
it concentrated on the production of course earthenware and on so called
Delftware,
which was in imitation of the Delft pottery produced in the Netherlands.
Production of that kind of pottery doubled in the late 17th century.
Then they moved on to stoneware,
particularly after the 1680s and as the potteries expanded employment in this
industry.
Trebled.
This was the age would store the foundation just a decade or two later of such
firms that are still familiar as Wedgewood and Royal Doulton in that area of the
potteries,
the West Midlands metal wares.
We're also taking off the city of Sheffield in South Yorkshire,
had long been involved in the production of edge tools,
but they began to diversify.
They began to produce scissors and files and metal buttons and razors and forks.
Forks were a novelty prior to this period.
People ate their meat by stabbing it with a pointed knife and putting it in
their mouths.
Folks were coming in.
Sheffield was manufacturing them for this new market.
They were amongst the decencies of life in the West Midlands.
There was comparable growth around Birmingham,
especially from the 60 nineties Birmingham had long made nails and tools and
weaponry and saddlers ironmongery,
but they began to make fancy buckles and buttons and pots and pans and kettles
and what they described as toys.
Toys was steal jewelry,
often made with WIA twisted in elaborate ways.
They began specializing also in the production of boxes which imitated Japanese
imports.
It was known as Japan in the production of lacquered boxes in imitation of these
popular products which had been introduced by the trade with the east.
In this version,
they would affordable by people of the middle link sought not simply by the
elite.
They also had big markets in guns,
many of which would export it to North America and to Africa and they supplied
the planters of the American colonies with casp nails with holes with sugar cane
knives,
with chains for their oxen to pull heavy weights and so forth.
And so one could go on for other less dramatic developments in regional
industrial specialization and growth.
And finally,
all of this required of course raw materials.
Some of those raw materials were being imported.
Another stimulus to trade the cotton from the Mediterranean,
the steel from Sweden,
some specialized high quality wools,
which we used in the woolen manufacturers.
They came from Spain,
some of them,
but a great deal of the raw materials used were being produced at home.
The period saw a major expansion in the iron and steel industries from the
sixties and seventies tin mining down in the southwest in Cornwall took off
copper mining,
expanded lead mining in Darbyshire in the Midlands.
Yeah.
And in north Wales also increased very significantly and there was a massive
growth in the coal industry.
Coal being the ubiquitous fuel,
not only for domestic fires,
but for any industrial process which required heat.
They still couldn't use it for smelting iron,
but they used it in many other industrial processes which simply required a
source of heat.
So coal production in Newcastle in the northeast,
which had already been a prodigious half a million tons in 1650 was 1.3 million
by 1700 and over 2 million by 1750 and there were significant expansions of coal
production in other areas to areas where it hadn't been previously economical to
produce in transport.
Coal now got involved because demand had increased the coal industry,
bread,
other innovations,
steam engines were invented at the end of the 17th century to drain coal mines.
That was their original purpose,
wooden wagon ways,
railways built of wood along which wagons would run to transport coal more
cheaply and easily.
Wagons pulled by horses were introduced from the 1660s and were commonplace in
the coal mining areas by the early 18th century.
One proud Colonna said that one of his wagon ways,
which he'd built for several miles to get his Coulter to market was as
prodigious,
uh,
an engineering feat as the via Appia near Rome.
And he was right,
some of these industrial undertakings where the biggest silver civil engineering
projects,
which had been undertaken in Britain since the Romans had left.
Eventually of course you put together the steam engines,
the drain,
the mine mines with the railways,
the wagon ways that carried the coal.
And you have locomotives,
George Stevenson.
So in the areas of growth of this kind,
especially as you live noticed areas in the north and in the Midlands and in
parts of the West country.
The picture is one of what's been described as industrial agglomeration,
a greater density of involvement in particular areas and that kind of
agglomeration as more and more communities are involved in these activities had
many effects.
It could reduce transportation costs,
it could encourage spinoff developments,
it could encourage the spread of innovations,
the transmission of skills amongst the local population well used to its
involvement in these industries,
the formation of partnerships to raise capital flows of information regarding
markets and innovative products and processes.
It resulted eventually in the creation of highly specialized local economies,
distinctive occupational regions,
the coal mining areas of the northeast,
the cloth weaving areas of the West country,
the metal where areas of Birmingham and so forth.
These were essentially the origins of the distinctive regional identities of
industrial Britain as it was to be the roots of some of this activity.
Of course,
lane deepen the past,
especially the cloth industry,
but the period between 1660 and the mid 18th century saw the full emergence of
all of this activity as part of a new regional economic structure.
Okay.
Now of course,
every one of those zones was centered upon a major town or towns.
Another part of the story of urban growth and the interconnections between them
were facilitated by the role of towns as central places in the circulating
systems of commerce.
The late 17th and very early 18th centuries saw a second great wave of
intensification in internal trade comparable to but exceeding that which had
taken place in the late 16th century trade in both agricultural and industrial
products.
It was a great age of improvement in communications as well as in agriculture
and manufacturers.
Without improvement in communications,
this kind of regional specialization wouldn't have been possible.
You had to be able to move the goods around.
Effectively.
The coastal trade grew enormously.
It's been that the,
the long coastline of Britain became like one great river with coastal traffic
flowing to and fro
efforts were made also to improve the navigation of the great river systems,
the Thames,
the seven,
the Trent and so forth.
There were over 40 acts of parliament for river navigation improvement schemes
passed between 60 and 60 and 1700 efforts were also made to improve the roads
turn pack trusts were devised as a way of improving road quality by charging a
toll,
the money from which would be used to maintain a higher quality highway.
All of the major routes in the county of Gloucestershire just around Bristol,
we're turned pact between 60 90 and 1740 to take just one regional example,
every major route there had been turnpike and proliferating turn piking was
taking place all over the kingdom radiating out in particular from London.
Along those improved roads were improved,
regular carrier services delivering goods to and fro throughout the kingdom.
So in a sense it was an age of intensified traffic on all these arteries of
communication by river around the coast,
along the turnpike roads.
And that inevitably produced an intensifying relationship of exchange between
urban and rural society,
between different rural regions.
The influence of all of this activity percolating right down to the level of the
individual village.
One indicator of that to close is the proliferation of village shops in this
period.
It's a period which sees a proliferation of little shops in villages.
For example,
in a far from far from prominent place up here in the leg district and the
northwest,
the town of Kirby Lonsdale.
There was a man called Abraham Dent who kept a shop at the turn of the 18th
century is inventory survives.
It lists all the goods that he stocked and the suppliers to whom he owed money.
Very useful.
Abraham Dent stock goods from 51 different origins,
some of them way overseas yet his tobacco,
he had his sugar and so forth and many English manufactured products.
He had bought goods from 190 different suppliers scattered all over the country
and they'd reached him in his obscure town in the lake district.
Such local tradesmen as Abraham Dent showed how far England's local economies
had moved away from the era era of relative self sufficiency,
which I described at the beginning of this lecture course and the existence of
shops like den symbolize in a sense the completion of a massive process of
commercial integration and transition.
John Brewer puts it very well when he says the shopkeeper linked the market town
and the local community to a network of markets that now stretched beyond the
nation's boundaries across oceans,
across continents and that's correct.
They link together the farmers,
the craft's people,
the merchants,
the semen,
the hunters,
the plantation slaves or linked together in an increasingly closely articulated
whole a market economy and nascent world economy.
Some people describe all this as archaic globalization.
Some of the earliest stages of that familiar process.
It's a commercial civilization in which Britain increasingly played a core role.
It was still,
as ea Wrigley has put it an organic economy.
It's still dependent pretty much on muscle power,
human and animal muscles or wind and water to pirates machinery and so forth.
It was not yet what he describes as the mineral based energy economy of the
industrial revolution era.
But if it was still an organic economy,
it was a very advanced organic economy and already in many ways beginning to
anticipate the transformations which would come in the later 18th century with
the introduction of steam power and mechanization.
So we'll leave it there.
Well,
have a good break and we'll reassemble to get the end of the story as far as the
state is concerned in the week after thanksgiving.